I want to take a few minutes and just
continue to explore this question about
word problems in Singapore mathematics
and really why they're so valuable and I
want to invoke kind of just a classic
example here so when I think about what
it would take to solve this problem how
we might solve it and why that's going
to be valuable for thought process for
students so I'm gonna use a method here
called bomb modeling which is pretty
ingrained and into the Singapore
mathematics method if you want some more
information on that there are other
videos on the website that really dive
into bar modelling but hopefully you can
see the value of bar modeling in this
problem and how it might help a student
but I want to compare this to what we
just would happen if you didn't actually
do this word problem what what
opportunities you'd be sacrificing for
students and what thoughts they wouldn't
get to be challenged to have different
skills they wouldn't be challenged to
build so let's think about what it would
take to solve this problem first well
this isn't a very easy one right it
looks pretty easy on the surface Christa
has $16 jessica has 11 more dollars than
Christa how much money do they have
altogether looks reasonably easy but
actually to a third grader right and
that's the textbook that I pulled this
out of this is actually a very difficult
problem this is what we might call a
two-step problem a lot of second third
graders and even some of you would try
to solve this by saying I see the number
16 I see the number 11 I see the word
altogether let's put 16 dollars and 11
dollars together we get 27 dollars let's
call it a day and really it's not the
right answer this problem here but also
the main thing here is trying to get
students to think beyond just these
keywords or these clues right that's not
really how we want to engage with word
problems is thinking about key words and
clues right really what we want to do is
to engage with the problem winner in a
pictorial fashion right and so I might
try to draw something here right so I
and I could start just by going slowly
so the one if you're teaching this and
there are other videos that are also
gonna help with with with this but if
you're teaching this go slowly go step
by step go you know and and draw as
you're going along I like to say reef a
little bit then stop and then draw a
little bit and then read and stop and
draw etcetera and so what I'm going to
do here right
Christa has $16 what I can do is I can
say Christa right has $16 here all right
and I've done is I've taken in the words
here and I've translated them into a
picture right Jessica has 11 more
dollars than Christa and there are all
sorts of questions you can ask the
teacher around this moment right do I
need to draw Jessica's bar bigger or
smaller right we can clue see it's gonna
be bigger how much bigger should I just
draw it to here should I draw all the
way across the board right trying to get
students to estimate how big it's gonna
drama don't you get an exact but just
trying to model it and somewhere around
there right and then figure out where I
can draw the 11 right the 11 actually
doesn't go in it doesn't apply to the
whole thing right Chris doesn't have 11
dollars
but Christa has 11 more dollars here all
right and sometimes you can even will
align there to show that Christa has 11
dollars right and then to finish this
off right how much money they have
altogether right we finished out every
bar model by thinking about a question
mark right and the question mark here is
gonna belong over here because I want to
know how much money they have altogether
and so what you can see here is this
pretty clearly a two-step process right
it's gonna be a two-step problem I can't
figure out how much they have all
together until I figure out how much
Jessica has right so I can start by
doing that start by saying what's this
and now you might get a student doing
something like 16 plus 11 over here
getting 27 and then we might actually
then progress and figure out the
question mark here or we would do 16
plus 27 giving us $43 right we might
finish it off just by saying they have
23 dollars
all together right what I want to do for
just a few seconds here first of all
hopefully you can see the value of bar
modeling into taking the most difficult
parts of this problem right why
shouldn't I just add 16/11 and be done
with it what operations do I choose how
do I know to do two steps in this
problem once I've drawn this picture
it's abundantly clear why I need to go
and do these things right value this
pictorial approach that Singapore
mathematics has but really let's think
about if students were only ever
challenged to do something like this and
you'll see some mathematics curricula
just keep keep hammering home these kind
of questions to students right without
any context without any word problem
without anything right I'm not actually
challenged to do the thinking that I am
when I'm actually given a word problem
not challenged to model I'm not trying
to translate I'm not all I'm challenged
to do is to manipulate symbols right
this encourages students challenged
students give students the opportunity
to do more than just symbols right gets
them thinking about how do I take
something that is a real-world problem
turn it into a model right and then come
up with an answer that I know makes
sense right and you can ask all sorts of
great questions about this as a teacher
right why does $43 make sense why
doesn't $27 make sense right if jessica
has 11 dollars more than Christa how
much morning does Jessica have right you
can think of all these questions that
you can ask as a teacher in a word
problem
you can't ask so much in these problems
right these problems have their own
great set of questions and we should
still teach students how to do this
right but it's not gonna ever take the
place of a word problem what problem is
gonna challenges students in a unique
fashion yes it is difficult yes it is
time-consuming but given the tools of
bar modeling it unlocks some
opportunities for students they're not
going to get anywhere else
you